pas
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ils sont fiers ces jeunes du collège
alsace corée à cilaos ils viennent de
remporter le premier prix toutes
catégories du concours d'embellissement
des collèges un concours qui amène les
collégiens à s'approprier leur
établissement en améliorant leur cadre
de vie
mais s'il est le
enfin il
l'accès des faits
lester b
l'embellissement du collège alsace corée
s'est fait par la création d'un
arboretum sur un espace en friche un
jardin qui regroupe des plantes
endémiques de la réunion et plus
particulièrement de cilaos un projet
fédérateur à la fois ludique et
pédagogique pages très heureux de
participer à ce projet chorus à nous
appeler reconnaître un peu plus sa
nature et toi qu'est ce que tu as fait
un jeu planté les arbres
et comme ça après ça on est parti mais
un peu partout pour rechercher les
graines des trucs comme ça oui ça m'a
plu parce que ça permet de phase a
permis d'avoir une bonne connectivité de
rassembler tout le monde et de fins de
d'embellir le collège donc c'est déjà
quelque chose de bien concret sur les 77
équipements de lille 20 établissements
ont décidé cette année de participer et
s'investir dans cette démarche
d'embellissement le département soutient
ces projets d'aménagement du milieu
scolaire sa patte
les agents les élèves les enseignants
toit de projets des différents par top
partenaires bien évidemment des piliers
à l'inscription dans un projet qui est
le concours
du le concours du conseil départemental
qui nous a permis un de commencer à
débloquer des financements à travers de
jolie enveloppe et finalement la
troisième va nous permettre de continuer
le projet notamment autour d'un axe de
repos et qu'on appelle l'amphi pour les
élèves et à deuxième projet un peu plus
un peu plus radia salle tendu parce
qu'ils demandent beaucoup de règles et
d'autorisation c'est l'installation de
ruches
le concours d'embellissement des
collèges contre cinq catégories 19
collèges ont été récompensés par un jury
composé d'élus de professionnels et de
membres d'associations
[Musique]